coué bienvenue à paroles autochtone si
c'est melissa maulin depuis cette
semaine en une question de joel lyrique
qui va nous la poser d'ailleurs que ce
serait la façon la plus respectueuse en
fait de faire référence à votre peau est
alors jouer lyrique qui me demande
quelle est la manière la plus
respectueuse de pouvoir présenter les
premières nations les peuples
autochtones les métis les inuits
alors la meilleure manière je peux
l'expliquer des fois c'est au début les
gens disaient d un tir quelques années
plus tard on a dit les amérindiens
aujourd'hui une des thématiques qu'on
utilise ces pots c'est le mot autochtone
je considère un peu comme un panier
qu'on note ici pour contenir toutes les
savoir que vous trouvez encore à
intégrer sur les nations comme moi je
suis à doc tonnes je m'explique pas ce
que ça va ça comprend le dis que je suis
originaire d'ici originaire du pays mais
maintenant beaucoup de gens même des
québécois qui ont des origines
françaises vont dire je suis autochtone
moi aussi je suis originaire d'ici mais
ce que l'on veut dire c'est surtout je
suis d'une nation qui est là depuis des
milliers d'années donc un moment dgr de
dire je suis nous et que tout le monde
va comprendre ça veut dire quoi être in
ou puis je veux dire je suis inondé
quantity halal on peut comprendre aussi
ce que ça veut dire être une ou deux
pointes chic parce qu'il ya quand même
distinction et un jour probablement qu
avoir la chance de pouvoir se dire juste
chez des coins titre et le monde va
comprendre tout l'historique qui vient
avec où je suis il nous est tout
l'historique qui vient avec
et tellement vrai me demander à wade
quelques munauté passer d une manière
que je pense qu'il est très respectueuse
de s'adresser aux gens c'est de leur
demander de quelle nation y sont de kehl
communauté ils viennent et de
s'intéresser justement à leur provenance
et un jour justement le mot autochtone
le mot indien le mot amérindiens ne
seront plus déterminés des terminaisons
qui sera terminologie s'cusez moi qui
vont être utilisés pour nous définir on
va vraiment s'adresser à nous en tant qu
individus qui ont des origines très
distinctes la même manière et quelqu'un
va être fier de dire qu'il vient de
chicoutimi ou du lac saint jean donc
merci beaucoup pour ta question
en espérant qu'elle a pu répondre j'ai
pu y répondre
n'hésitez pas à nous en envoyer on adore
recevoir vos questions et on adore aussi
quand vous partager les vidéos et je
souhaite une très belle semaine